keeping with the ego-driven writer
versus one that's doing it more for
their own healing or for the greater
good
do you see maybe a younger writer let's
say under 30 who's gone through early
childhood trauma have maybe what they
call an old soul
yeah and more of a authentic voice
versus someone who had an idyllic
childhood but hasn't really had that
sort of thing that's really gonna change
them yet happen yet hasn't had the
moment of loss like the humbling life
moment they all have lost I think I
I've had both writers I've definitely I
know when I was staffing at the studio
that what I found was writers would get
so hung up on should I get a masters
degree should I you know this should I
that should I have studied film and I
think what I came to found find was that
writers who went from undergrad to
masters and I actually haven't even had
writers who who got their MFA and then
got the law degree and and then they go
to the writers room and that's like they
haven't experienced enough of life
that's like they've been in a school
room and they haven't really known the
ups and downs versus a 30 year old
writer I remember I recently had a
writer who was under 30 who I said to
her what do you think your voice is and
she said oh I know what my voice is I
tend to write teen drama where there is
an underdog element and it's it's moving
through that the stresses that are
involved with that and I said all right
I like that do you know what your wound
is where that came from and she's like
oh I absolutely know my wound and it was
so like this was an old soul like she
had such a clip such clarity with where
what she wants to say through story was
coming from and she said my mom had many
kids before she was ready and two of my
siblings had autism and Asperger's and
my mom wasn't ready to deal with that so
I became the parent and so I felt
emotionally abandoned by my mom and I
write stories where the central
characters wound is emotional
abandonment Wow
so that for me was like I was like all
right you're a writer like you
understand how to process life and bring
it to the page and you understand at
such an early age what you have to say
you